leading the charge are the public health
officers Teresa Tam is the federal
officer and each province and territory
has their own they never seek the
limelight now though they are some of
the most famous and beloved leaders in
the country their daily briefings are
where canadians turn to get the facts
and learn about the science BC's public
health officer dr. Bonnie Henry is so
beloved she's inspired a fan club
t-shirts street art and musical tributes
she's also keenly aware that this virus
came out of nowhere and that makes it
very hard to predict where it's going
dr. Henry I know you are so incredibly
busy thank you for taking the time to
talk to us you know I want to start by
asking when we watched what happened in
China and saw what this virus is capable
of back in January how it overwhelmed
the hospitals that it killed even health
care workers entire cities were put
under lockdown did you think what was
happening there could happen here do you
have a forgive me but a kind of holy
crap moment absolutely and I think you
know when talking about it with with my
colleagues to the media to the public at
the time we were holding out hope that
China would be able to contain this but
it became apparent not long after I mean
I knew we would undoubtedly have cases
in in Canada and in BC just given the
travel patterns that we knew around the
world I don't think I was prepared for
how severe it was going to be in other
countries particularly when it hit
Europe and many of us I think around the
world when we saw what was happening in
Italy was really shocking these were all
the things that we had talked about in
preparing for pandemics for a long time
but I never really thought that I would
actually have to do them but I think you
know here in Canada we we had the luxury
of time to prepare us and to help us
understand what things need it to be
done you have so much experience with
the SARS outbreak in Toronto where you
helped lead the response and the Ebola
outbreak in Uganda
those were life and death challenges -
how does what you're doing now compared
to that you know I think every pandemic
is different every outbreak is different
all of them have their challenges this
one certainly is unprecedented in the
impacts that it's had around the world
and you know as you say I've been
involved with many very serious very
tragic outbreaks and this one just the
the whole societal impacts of it have
been immense you have such a fine
balance to keep as a public health
officer informing people but not
panicking people deciding when an asked
becomes an order it's critical that you
keep the public on your side throughout
this how much does that weigh on you a
lot of it weighs on me it weighs on me
you know we want to put in enough
restrictions to do what we need to do to
contain this virus right now we know
there's there's no treatment there's no
prevention if you've been exposed we
just need to make sure that we can care
for you appropriately and that we do
everything we can so you don't pass it
on to somebody else but every single
measure that we take that unintended
consequences the numbers of people who
have had their lives disrupted whether
it's from kovat 19 and the tragedies in
our long-term care homes or whether it's
people who have had their surgeries
cancelled or people who are unemployed
because of the the huge economic fallout
I think that you know the everything
about this has been so challenging and
that the sort of balance of trying to
get just enough restriction to do what
we need to do but not too much and it it
haunts me a little bit because you can't
ever get it just right though there is
widespread transmission in some areas of
the world we are not in that position
yet I know you are a doctor dr. Henry
not a TV personality your briefings have
happened almost every day though for 12
weeks now you've become must-see TV and
British Columbia
P
or drawing pictures of you and murals of
you I'm sure they're sending you things
and they're writing songs about you
that's a barbershop quartets in the
Naima they love you it's it's pretty
remarkable isn't it can you see me
blushing that was beautiful certainly
have amazing voices I guess what I'm
asking is what do you think it says
about how the public is looking to
people like you to public health
officers and to experts and to science
to lead us out of this well I am
heartened that people are looking to
experts into science particularly in
Canada and you know I've said this many
times what I do is I'm the face and
sometimes the voice of a lot of people
and a lot of people who are very
committed and passionate and doing the
work on the ground and we are a team and
we are a team across the country we know
each other well we talk all the time
sometimes daily these days but it is a
privilege and very humbling for me to
represent the work that so many people
are doing to try and keep us safe in our
communities across this country the
million-dollar question is when this
will end now I know there's no precise
answer to that I'm not gonna ask you
that but what about an exit strategy a
plan for a ladder if you like that we
can start climbing to get out of this
you must be working on that absolutely
and in the same way that we were
watching China we were watching Italy
we're watching Singapore Hong Kong
Germany we're now watching them and
seeing where you know in some ways again
we have the luxury of everybody else
going before us right now of course we
are still very much in the middle of
things in the United States and across
Canada but we are seeing what measures
others are doing and how it works so
clearly watching Luhan very closely
where they've just relisted the
restrictions quite a lot
and we have the luxury of some modeling
we have some really brilliant minds that
have been looking at this looking at
what we might think of over time and yes
we are planning from the very first day
we put the first measures in place my
goal my aim and our direction to people
was all right what do we need to know
that we're in a place where we can stop
doing some of these things I think the
reality is that some things are going to
change for a long time maybe 18 months
maybe years things around distancing
things around cleaning our hands
regularly the things that do protect us
that that safe distance between us until
we have a herd immunity or community
immunity whether that's because people
have been infected or hopefully because
we have a vaccine that prevents us from
getting sick with this virus we're going
to have to do some things for quite some
time when is it time dr. Henry to tell
the public what that strategy is how it
will work when some of the restrictions
can be lifted and how that will happen
none of us are in the place right now
where we can consider how we're going to
lift restrictions that doesn't mean we
we aren't thinking about it and we need
to think about it but we need to be
realistic about the fact that we have a
few more weeks before we can start
actually implementing these things and
we'll talk more about what that looks
like in the near future but right now it
has to be done in a very thoughtful way
and a very a way that makes sure that we
have those surveillance pieces in place
so we know if we're starting to get more
cases again that might lead to outbreaks
and overwhelm our health system so it's
going to be a fine balance for a while
you know we sometimes talk about the
cases in the deaths as if they are
statistics they are of course and we all
know they're individual people you are
making life-and-death decisions there
must be times when that really hits you
absolutely and you know it's the thing
that keeps me up awake at night more
than anything is you know have we missed
things what have we done enough in this
area or that area you know that the
tragedies of you know recently we've had
people who've died from this at home
what can we do differently how can we
support people and the other part of it
that's so important is these measures
these unprecedented measures we've put
in place across the world you know the
impact on children the impact on people
who can't who haven't been able to get
their their surgery that they need it's
been a it's it's very challenging to to
reconcile all of those and of course
everybody who who dies from this who's
affected by this their family their
caregivers their community but I also
think you know that's what that is why
people are willing and able and are
doing what we've asked them to do around
social distancing around keeping their
in keeping that safe distance for people
staying close to their family working
from home because we know that if we get
sick with this it is our loved ones our
family in our close community that we're
going to pass it to so all of us are in
this together
and I think you know if that's the
impetus so many of us have to make sure
we're doing the right things